si vous preniez deux minutes pour
écouter mais je sais que ça tu écoutais
tu veux encore une quête ans doit être
jugée très sérieuse lui mais sûre et
certaine que ça va marcher
c'était une si bonne année la toison
d'or peut guérir toutes choses ou toute
personne qui vante y compris l'arbre de
talia si on guérit l'arbre ont réparé la
barrière et le camp de risque plus rien
je suis surpris que vous soyez d'accord
avec quelle mesure enders underwood
c'est pas grave vous devez savoir que
tous les satyres qui ont cherché la
toison d'or sont morts voilà qui
n'arrête pas de lui dire mais mais c'est
un risque que je suis prêt à prendre
pour le bien commun
écoutez la dernière fois que j'en ai
entendu parler la toison d'or se
trouvait dans la mer des monstres que
les humains appelle le triangle des
bermudes un endroit redoutable pour tout
le monde pas que pour les satyres et
donc la réponse est non non je suis
navré à la belle à la baisse c'est pas
grave c'est une très mauvaise idée